der bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes schützen können auch wenn die
lage anders ist weil so viele geimpft
sind ist sie noch nicht gut ganz
besonders deshalb weil nicht genügend
bürger und bürger von der
impfmöglichkeit bisher gebrauch gemacht
haben und deshalb müssen wir weiter
vorsichtig sein wir müssen vorsichtig
sein und bleiben und zb dafür sorge
tragen dass die massen pflicht weiter
beachtet und durchgesetzt werden kann
das den verkehrsbetrieben sie genutzt
wird oder bei veranstaltungen das
abstandsregeln gelten hygieneregeln
impft nachweise vorgelegt werden müssen
all die dinge die wir schon kennen sie
werden auch weiter für die nächste zeit
erforderlich sein und das ist ein
unterschied zwischen unserem land und
anderen ländern die sich entschieden
haben ganz auf solche vorsichtsregeln zu
verzichten wir halten sie weiter für
erforderlich
und wir müssen noch darüber hinaus viele
viele weitere maßnahmen ergreifen die
notwendig sind damit wir durch diesen
winter kommen wir müssen gewissermaßen
unser land winterfest machen
deshalb bin ich über einige dieser dinge
und maßnahmen sprechen die jetzt
erforderlich sind über die in diesem
gesetzespaket zu entscheiden sein wird
und auch über die maßnahmen geht darum
herum auf den weg gebracht werden und im
rahmen der gesetzesberatung noch
dazukommen werden das aller erste und
wichtigste ist wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen bei dem versuch möglichst
viele bürgerinnen und bürger zu impfen
es haben sich noch nicht alle überzeugt
dass das für sie richtig ist und wir
sollten eine große gemeinsame kampagne
starten dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
von dieser möglichkeit gebrauch machen
die hausärzte die mobilen angebote sind
da und wir brauchen wieder mehr
impfzentren wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass sie wieder eröffnet werden
und wir sollten auch gemeinsam dafür
sorge tragen dass die eröffneten
impfzentren auch gemeinsam auch mit
mitteln des bundes finanziert werden
und wir brauchen sie auch weil wir
natürlich jetzt alles dafür tun müssen
dass millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
eine auffrischungsimpfung bekommen dass
sie sich boostern lassen dass millionen
bürgern und bürger die
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen und
monate
und noch dazu und auch dazu wird es
erforderlich sein dass wir diese
möglichkeiten haben die aktivitäten der
hausärzte die mobilen angebote und die
impfzentren und wir sollten das möglich
machen was jetzt in einem gemeinsamen
schreiben des bundesgesundheitsministers
und der ärzteverbände an alle hausärzte
und ärzte formuliert worden ist nämlich
dass man nach sechs monaten eine
auffrischungsimpfung erhalten kann soll
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass das
auch tatsächlich überall in deutschland
möglich ist
ganz besonders ist es wichtig dass wir
jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass die
älteren schnell geimpft werden und die
dritte impfung bekommen die booster
impfung und darum will ich an dieser
stelle auch die pflegeheime ansprechen
die so wichtig sind das war nicht zu
ertragen was wir am anfang der pandemie
erlebt haben dass so viele bürgerinnen
und bürger erkrankt sind die in dem
pflegeheim gelebt haben dass so viele
gestorben sind und das darf uns in
diesem winter nicht mehr passieren
deshalb müssen wir alle notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen damit das nicht
geschieht es muss täglich getestet
werden wer dort arbeitet und nicht
geimpft ist und alle besuchern und
besucher müssen ein test bekommen dass
es für die sicherheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger die in den
pflegeeinrichtungen leben erforderlich
und natürlich müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass überall in diesen
bereichen gemustert wird dass die
impfung durchgeführt werden das ist
längst vereinbart und das muss jetzt mit
großer geschwindigkeit geschehen die
geschwindigkeit muss er zunehmend zu dem
was wir bisher haben und deshalb bin ich
sehr froh dass es hier das vorhaben gibt
dafür zu sorgen dass die durchsetzung
des boosters der auffrischungsimpfung in
dem pflegeheim auch ge monitor wird dass
wir für jedes einzelne pflegeheim wissen
wie weit es ist das ist die aufgabe die
wir jetzt ganz in deutschland
durchsetzen müssen
wir werden weiter dafür sorge tragen
dass an den schulen getestet wird und
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
arbeitsplätze sicher sind darum haben
wir gespräche geführt mit den
gewerkschaften mit betriebsrat mit
vielen anderen mit arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmern und mit den unternehmen
und wir sind sicher wir müssen eine
zusätzliche vorsichtsmaßnahmen am
arbeitsplatz treffen deshalb wollen wir
das in zukunft an arbeitsplätzen 3 gilt
man muss dort arbeiten wir haben an
geimpft ist genesen oder aber einen test
haben und das ist eine notwendige
verbesserung
und auch das muss jetzt geschehen dass
wir die möglichkeit nutzen die mit dem
neuen gesetz verbunden sind dort sind
den ländern alle kompetenzen eröffnet
damit sie differenziert nach den
einzelnen bereichen entscheidungen
treffen können über 3g konzepte für den
zutritt zu gaststätten zum beispiel zur
veranstaltung zu geschäften und allen
möglichen aber eben auch zu zwei gehen
und ich habe das so verstanden dass
viele länder sich jetzt auf den weg
gemacht haben und überall bei sich
entscheidungen treffen dass sie
insbesondere bei gaststätten und
veranstaltungen bei kinos und theater
besuchen zweig vorschreiben wollen ich
halte das für einen guten fortschritt
dass das überall gemacht wird die
möglichkeiten dafür schaffen wir jetzt
für all das was jetzt notwendig es gilt
aber auch eine sache ganz entschieden es
muss auch umgesetzt werden deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass wir das monitoring
machen im hinblick auf die
altenpflegeeinrichtung und einrichtungen
der eingliederungshilfe
aber deshalb ist es auch wichtig dass
wir sicherstellen dass an den
restaurants in deutschland tatsächlich
die zutritts kriterien auch überwacht
werden es kann nicht sein dass wir
solche vorschriften haben und jeder geht
ein restaurant und merkt dass sie nicht
beachtet wird gilt nicht für alle aber
gilt an vielen stellen
damit man diesen weg gehen kann damit
wäre deutschland winterfest machen
können ist es aber auch wichtig dass wir
den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
rahmenbedingungen zur verfügung stellen
die für sie ist gestaltbar machen damit
umzugehen und darum bin ich froh dass
wir gemeinsam uns vorgearbeitet haben zu
der einsicht dass es notwendig ist dass
die möglichkeit kostenloser test für die
bürgerinnen und bürger wieder eröffnet
wird wir werden jetzt die voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass es kostenlose test
gibt die zb in apotheken oder bei den
maltesern oder an anderen einrichtungen
verfügbar sind für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem lande dann sind nämlich
auch 3g konzepte in den betrieben und
zweige vorschriften möglich und 3g
vorschriften alles das kann man machen
wenn man tests anbietet herr scholz
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fdp fraktion
und dann glaube ich müssen wir uns
natürlich damit auseinandersetzen dass
das virus eben nicht weg ist dass wir
all diese maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
aber es trotzdem dazu kommen wird dass
viele bürgerinnen und bürger sich
infizieren und ganz besonders diejenigen
die sich nicht habe schützen lassen und
die nicht geimpft sind wir sind in der
wirklich schwierigen situation dass wir
genügend impfstoff haben dass jeder sich
und jeder sich impfen lassen könnte aber
dass es keineswegs alle gemacht haben
bisher und wir wissen was die konsequenz
sein wird sehr sehr vielen von denen die
nicht geimpft sind werden sich
infizieren und viele von dem die sich
infizieren werden werden krank war und
von diesen die sich für in die krank
werden werden einige auf den
intensivstationen
unser krankenhäuser um ihr leben ringen
das ist die situation die uns bevorsteht
und deshalb müssen wir hier eine
abwägungsentscheidung treffen eine
abwägungsentscheidung wie wir trotz der
tatsache dass
die impf angebote nicht wahrgenommen
worden sind uns um den schutz des lebens
dieser bürgerinnen bürger auch mit allen
unseren möglichkeiten kümmern und das
hat eine konsequenz nämlich die
konsequenz dass wir sagen wir werden den
krankenhäusern die finanziellen mittel
geben dass sie jetzt operationen neu
aufteilen
dass die operationen verschieben können
die verschiebbar sind damit sie platz
haben für die korona patienten die jetzt
behandelt werden müssen denn bei allem
was man unterschiedlich diskutieren mag
über das impfen wir müssen schutz für
die gesundheit aller bürger bürger
bieten und wir müssen ihnen diesen
schutz der krankenhäuser ermöglichen
das ist jetzt das gesetzespaket das wird
beraten hier im deutschen bundestag
es wird beraten zwischen den parteien
und ich will ausdrücklich sagen ich
finde es sehr schön wenn das
parteiübergreifend getragen wird weit
über die parteien hinaus die künftige
regierung bilden wollen das ist
jedenfalls die absicht und ich möchte
alle an den laden mitzumachen hier in
dieser wichtigen gesundheitskrise müssen
wir über parteigrenzen und über
regierung und opposition hinweg
zusammenarbeiten
und wir müssen lernen auch mit den
ländern sprechen und den gemeinden über
das was dann zusätzlicher unterstützung
notwendig ist und wie wir all das was
jetzt hier möglich gemacht wird auch
umsetzen das muss ja in der wirklichkeit
sich wiederfinden und deshalb wird es
auch die kanzlerin und ich sind darüber
einig wird es auch in der nächsten woche
ein gespräch ganz klassisches gespräch
zwischen der bundesregierung und den
ministerpräsidenten und den
ministerpräsidenten der länder geben um
die umsetzungsschritte genau zu
besprechen die sich aus all dem was ihr
auf den weg gebracht wird ergeben wird
das ist das was wir jetzt brauchen dass
das land zusammenhält und an einem
strang zieht in eine richtung damit wir
diesen winter überstehen und mein
letzter wunsch an die bürgerinnen und
bürger dies bisher noch nicht gemacht
haben lassen sie sich impfen es ist
wichtig für ihre gesundheit und es ist
gesicht ich für unser land schön danke
und da klatscht die fdp da klatschen die
grünen für den noch vizekanzler olaf
scholz der kanzler werden will und der
hier sein corona plan für die nächsten
wochen vorgestellt hat der entscheidende
satz von olaf scholz gerade wir müssen
unser land winterfest machen wo man sich
ein bisschen fragt wir sind ja schon
sehen ich weiß nicht ob du schon deine
winterreifen aufgezogen hass aufs auto
also nur die meisten deutschen haben
genau das gemacht haben ihr auto schon
mal winterfest gemacht deutschland ist
bei corona noch nicht winterfest sagt
olaf scholz das muss erst noch passieren
er paukt jetzt seinen den ampel corona
plan durchs parlament bei uns im studio
unsere politik korrespondentin lydia
rosenfelder und corona expertin sagt es
einmal was sind die entscheidenden
punkte von olaf scholz vom ampel corona
plan mit dem er jetzt deutschland
winterfest machen möchte also ich
verstehe dieses winterfest machen so
dass er jetzt vor allem auf die impfung
drängt aber in einer für scholz typisch
nüchternen art das finde ich positiv
also er macht nicht druck er droht nicht
so wie es immer mehr in der politischen
sprache einzug hält im umgang mit
ungeimpften sondern erwirbt dafür diese
impfung zu machen und er sagt aber
trotzdem auch ganz klar auch ungeimpfte
werden im krankenhaus behandelt der wir
ermöglichen das den krankenhäusern dass
sie das stemmen können und das finde ich
so sagen erst mal im sprachduktus gut
und ich glaube es ist zielführender weil
länder wie bremen zum beispiel mit einer
sehr hohen impfquoten das völlig ohne
druck schaffen einfach nur durch gutes
organisieren das zweite ist das testen
das soll täglich passieren in
altenheimen das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiges mittel das will jetzt die
ampel auch einführen und es soll weder
den kostenlosen bürger tests geben und
damit hat man auch wieder viel mehr
sicherheit zum beispiel wenn man sich an
weihnachten und seine familie treffen
will kann man vorher im test machen
impfen und testen das ist glaube ich
sind die winterreifen das sind die
winterreifen die wir brauchen wir
schauen zu angelika hellemann sie hat
für uns die rede von olaf scholz
verfolgt ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
angelika was sind die wichtigsten punkte
an wir uns jetzt in den kommenden wochen
und monaten gewöhnen müssen wenn dann
alles super durchgehend wie olaf scholz
gerade präsentiert hat und wie hat diese
rede diese so ja auch wichtige rede für
dich wo er das erste mal als kanzler von
deutschland aufgetreten ist gewirkt
das ist ein typischer olaf sound olaf
scholz sound gewesen an denen wir uns
wahrscheinlich gewöhnen werden wenn er
den kanzler ist also sehr zuversichtlich
ausstrahlt wir handeln wir haben die
sache im griff das ist so das was er als
politik und als kanzler ausstrahlen will
er hat ja immer die korona politik der
kanzlerin mitgetragen womit er nie so
richtig einverstanden war war dieser
sehr alarmistische ton den hat er auch
weniger angeschlagen und da hat sieht
man jetzt eine verschiebung
gleichzeitig versucht da halt auch den
ländern die verantwortung zuzuschieben
es ist klar mit der fdp gibt es kein
bundesweites zweig jetzt ermuntert er
aber die bundesländer zweig einzuführen
wenn jetzt alle 16 bundesländer das
täten dann haben wir auch bundesweites
zweig das ganz interessant dass er
sozusagen diesen schlenker wählt weil
dann ja auch sein koalitionspartner gar
nicht nutzen kann weil es sind dann ja
die ministerpräsidenten die so handeln
und eine möglichkeit einfach nehmen für
die menschen wird glaube ich dass für
sie im alltag neueste seien die bürger
tests kommen zurück und es gilt halt 3g
am arbeitsplatz das hat er gerade sehr
vollmundig kurz angekündigt und es
wirkte so als ob alles schon geklärt ist
das ist es aber noch nicht denn was so
einfach klingt und so logisch wir machen
das am arbeitsplatz sicher dann gibt es
da halt 3g ist gar nicht so einfach denn
die arbeitgeber müssen dann ja
kontrollieren und es wäre ja irgendwie
ziemlich dumm wenn vor den fabriken und
vor den großen bürohäusern lange
schlangen sind weil halt ganz mühsam
kontrolliert wird also es wird
wahrscheinlich eine fast lane geben
müssen für die geimpften und genesenen
und einer extra reihe wo halt genau sich
der test angeguckt wird der dann immer
tagesaktuell sein muss es wird noch
darum gerungen wie denn die bezahlung
geht also klar man kann sich einen
kostenfreien bürger test jeden morgen
organisieren aber dann muss man auch
extra wegstrecke 1 planen weil nicht
geplant ist dass es wieder all diese pop
up stores gibt dies in der ersten
testphase gegeben hat sondern für die
kostenlosen bürger test sollen halt
wirklich nur die testzentren die jetzt
schon bestehen weiter laufen und bak und
ähnliche institutionen die sollen noch
einmal zusätzliche zentren einrichten
können